boy certainly someone I've admired a lot
I did try to talk to him once at a party
and it was super rude to me Larry Page
is an old friend of mine I've known
Larry since before he got Venture
funding for Google I mean he obviously
was an incredible guy and made fantastic
products God has certain magic about him
you know sort of that was kind of that
was really inspiring so I mean I think
that's that's really great is there is
there that man that man you trying to
emulate uh no I I think Steve Jobs is
way cooler than than I am so
hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because in my first
business I struggled to believe in
myself I quit on my business partner and
the thing that saved me was watching the
successful stories of entrepreneurs they
gave me the inspiration to keep going as
well as the strategies of what to do and
quite honestly I still need their
stories and motivation today as well so
today let's live your best believe life
and learn what successful entrepreneurs
think about Steve Jobs enjoy
[Music]
I think that Steve Jobs came along
became an icon
but the sad part of that narrative was
he did not treat his employees well he
became an icon and the narrative became
he got the most out of people by being a
jerk and that became romanticized and a
lot of people in Silicon Valley today
run companies where they're mean because
they think that's the right thing to do
because they put Steve Jobs on a
pedestal I want my pedestal moment I
want to become that big and what I want
to come from that is that kids that
aren't even born today think that they
can build a five billion dollar company
and be a great guy or a great gal I want
to build the biggest building in town
ever by just building the biggest
building in town while I think most
people try to tear down everybody else's
building it's really easy to imitate the
the bad parts of Steve of at times being
an uh and it is I have yet to meet any
person who in terms of picking Talent
hyper motivating that Talent uh and
having a sense of design of the this is
good this is not good so he brought some
incredibly positive things along with
that toughness and I always said that I
was like a minor wizard because he would
be casting spells and I would see people
mesmerized but because I'm a minor
wizard the Spells don't work on me I
could not cast those spells but I see I
see them and I would say hey wait don't
don't you're you're going to work even
more than I would ask you to this is no
this is crazy or or you know like when
he did the next introduction
which is a computer that completely
failed it was such nonsense and yet he
mesmerized those people like oh yes
Million by a million in Black Cube and
all this stuff and I was like wait a
minute that spell should not work at all
it doesn't have any reality to it so
Steve is a very singular case where the
company really was on a path to die and
it goes and becomes the most valuable
company in the world with some products
that are really quite amazing that there
aren't going to be many uh stories like
that two words Steve Jobs
um
toughest bastard you've ever met he is
tough he was you know I went to his his
uh so I called him up
um I said to him listen Steve you have
two and a half percent of the market and
we are your number sorry what year is
this this is
1998. before Apple ruled the universe
they were in a wobbly situation yeah two
and a half percent share my development
cost of 54 million a year for his titles
you know I was the number one uh title
on the Mac platform for reading and math
and I I called him up and I said let's
see if I need to meet with you the
economic's not working for me
um he said sure I'll take a meeting with
you so we go out to Cupertino and uh job
shows up with probably seven other
Executives in the room Andre with my
head sales guys I said Steve thanks for
coming out I have a very simple request
we're gonna have to give me 54 million
dollars if you want me to develop the
next cycle of titles for the Mac because
there's no economics it makes sense for
me he looked at me and he just started
to berate me veronic every swear word
world just he said are you out of here
and then you got up and out of his chair
and he circled around and said you be
something I'm looking at him I'm stunned
like the guy is just beating me up
verbally I'm used to Hard Times so you
know whatever I said Hey listen this is
all great that are you going to give me
the 54 million bucks and he said get out
of here get in the pocket it's just
abusive like crazy I said okay this is
over I walk up to the parking lot and
there's one of these windows you have to
roll up to the bottom and he rolls up
he's yelling at me from Death of the
parking lot I looked out and said so can
we have a deal or not call me tomorrow
like if the guy just wanted to beat me
up because he was I guess frustrated
because he had a lot of pressure too so
anyways at the end of the day we
remained the number one
um player on the Mac platform we built a
business off it years later I met
Wozniak and uh it was a completely
different kind of guy but I understand
how jobs worked there's a certain amount
of fear in that Organization for him I
mean he Chairs into people after he
looks at the Ia or anything of a product
and he'll rip their heads up yeah like
people don't want to get in an elevator
with him also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
Steve was clearly the most outstanding
business thinker and almost everybody
who's high up in the technology business
recognized that that somehow he had the
ability to think out new ways of doing
things not just ways to improve what we
have do a better version of something
but do it in a totally different way
that the world would swing towards and
then I think back to just all the times
we had together very very good times
that you have when you're young you know
and playing around with the systems and
a little misbehavior and doing
interesting things and and then he was
always thinking about certain technology
the early products that got developed
the building Parts what those might lead
to in our future and he was always
pushing me as an engineer could you
possibly add this someday could you
possibly have that someday yes yes yes I
could thinking no it's way way off but
eventually we all did we went into the
garage when we were two young people
with no money you have to work out of
your home we had jobs on the side we had
nobody that could loan US money we had
had no business experience we're like a
million young people who are so excited
about the future they might have someday
in business making something just out of
their ideas that's what we were yeah and
over and over and over all the products
of Apple from you know iPhones and iPads
iPods
um these were just unbelievable Life
Changers and uh almost everyone who
heads a technology company looks at
Steve Jobs is where did he get the ideas
to do it the right way we were just the
lucky partnership he was lucky to have
me in the beginning but I am much you
know incredibly lucky to him for
everything in my life he gets a
reputation for being a strong leader and
being Brash but to me he was just always
so kind such a good friend and
um I'm just gonna miss him all right
Steve Wozniak co-founder Apple thank you
very much
thank you
Steve Jobs I know people who knew him he
always said what he thought and and he
was pretty damn cut and dried about it
which is why the Apple products are such
miracles of of technological Mastery he
had a unbelievably canny design eye and
was very
uh
he cut whole projects
without a second thought in some sense
when they weren't working he did that
when he came back to Apple the second
time refined the entire product line got
rid of a ton of different things instead
of focusing on this yeah right right so
that was proof I mean maybe it was Luke
the first time which it wasn't but
coming back and doing it again the
second time showed pretty clearly it
wasn't Steve Jobs got fired from Apple
fundamentals matter and they brought in
John Scully a traditional entrepreneur
who or a traditional CEO who was good at
what he did but he wasn't the guy to
drive Apple to new heights they had to
bring Steve back that's just the nature
of great companies these guys you know
they don't cash out like me they stay
there because they're committed and
they're dedicated and you've got to take
the you know some of the
the uniqueness of each person as as part
of what you invest in when I first saw
Steve speak in person uh It Was 1980 I
was I was 15 years old and you know he
was mesmerizing and uh you know the
vision that he laid out for apple and
the personal computer was incredibly
powerful and
um yeah I did get to know him uh
certainly uh you know I I uh said some
things that that I I I uh you know well
I described it in the book in great
detail so you did the the whole yeah and
look I I think uh I think you know these
things get get uh made out to be uh they
take out a life of their own but but the
reality is that uh you know uh Steve and
I uh
we're able to to be friends and and uh
and and good friends and you know he his
birthday was uh one day uh after mine
and we had a a shared love for
particular uh place in the middle of the
Pacific Ocean
and uh we would often find ourselves
there on our on our birthdays and you
know spend spend time together and go go
on long walks and and talk about
technology in the world and our kids and
you know he was a singular Force
obviously uh you know now you've got
roughly five billion people in the world
connected carrying little computers
around with them and uh it's amazing
what's what's occurred uh you know uh
because of his his insistence and vision
and and uh and and focus
um so you know I don't think I don't
think it'll be another Steve Jobs Steve
meant so much to me and so much
to all of us there's not a day that goes
by
that we don't think about him
memories have especially come rushing
back
as we prepared
for today and this event
it's taken some time
but we can now reflect
on him with joy
instead of sadness
Steve's spirit and Timeless philosophy
on life
will always be the DNA of Apple
this question comes from Rim he says
that Steve Jobs was said to have a bad
temperament he often subjected his
employees to profanity fired them in
public and pushed them to the extreme
limits of performance
he is also considered one of the
greatest innovators of our time
such Behavior Justified as long as one
delivers results
[Music]
I don't usually like to make a personal
comment about somebody who's already
dead okay
but I'm asking you
one thing is what we do another thing is
what kind of human beings we are
is it important
what kind of human being you are hello
I did something what did I do I designed
a phone
if you did not design it Koreans would
have done it Chinese would have done it
Indians also beginning to do it
yes or no
there is a certain brand building
process in the world with which you can
build a brand
and see I want you to understand
you're a doctor at least
on the way
does this body need oxygen or carbon
dioxide boxes
but People Pumped carbon dioxide into
your bottle and said the real thing
Coca-Cola
it's the largest brand on the planet all
right
[Music]
more people drink at least all these
years more people drank Coca-Cola
then people did yoga or people did
anything else
in the remotest part of this country if
you went 20 years ago if you uttered the
word yoga they didn't know what it was
but if you said Coca-Cola they knew what
it was
[Music]
so just because it's branded like this
and marketed like this does it become
that your system has become such it
likes carbon dioxide and doesn't like
oxygen is it so
no
so you can brand things in so many ways
you don't go by these things you tell me
is it important
that you are a pleasant and wonderful
human being is it important for you
otherwise you look at it the other way
around
do you like to be shouted at right now I
can Shout
you you like to be shouting at no then
why do you think somebody else likes it
hello
you don't want to be abused isn't it
would you like to be abused
then why do you ever think that somebody
else likes it
when you don't like it
you know it is not nice to you why do
you do it to this person
why do you do that
you lost your Humanity fundamentally
isn't it
so just because you made a lot of money
I don't think it means anything
Alexander the Great idiot conquered half
the known world what does it mean it
doesn't mean a damn thing to me only a
fool would call such a man as a great
man
he just spent his whole life killing
people and you call him Alexander the
Great
no they forgot his third name it was
idiot
so please do not go by the standards
somebody has this much money
so he becomes a great man I don't think
so
anyway you untimely death with cancer
happened you didn't pack all your money
and go there's no container service in
the end
he went to the extent of saying
that whatever at that time he had some
46 billion dollars personal worth He
said even if I have to use this 46
billion dollars every dollar of it I
would like to destroy Google
because that is the
they are not making phones
but they have become more prominent in
the country so you want to kill it even
if you lose all your money there are
people like this even if both my eyes go
I want to take one eye of curse
this is the crudest level of existence
as far as I am concerned who is your
entrepreneurial Idol or who is your idol
in business I think uh Steve Jobs made
his own company got kicked out of it
made a new company got brought back into
his old company he's a superstar because
you made it this far in a video I want
to celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see
what successful entrepreneurs think
about Warren Buffett check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe then I'll
see you there I'm not as big but he does
like Capital allocation and he reads a
lot of sort of annual reports of
companies and pretty boring really and
he's trying to figure out is Coke or
Pepsi deserve more capital I mean that's
I mean it's kind of a boring job